l'adn peut contribuer au à résoudre des
enquêtes criminelles c'est exactement ce
que tentent de déterminer la biologiste
judiciaire sera noël qui a été recruté
par les experts du fbi pour améliorer
leur technique banquette savoir comment
l'utiliser sans doute cette expertise de
ces mon esprit madame noël
bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60 est absolument
fascinant
j'ai le goût de vous demandez-vous comme
biologiste judiciaire c'est d'abord
cette fois un rêve professionnel que
d'appartenir à une équipe comme celle du
rugby à ix pour faire avancer vos
techniques banquette
oui bah c'est certain que c'est une
marque de reconnaissance très importante
dans la catégorie des grands la réussite
d'un et qu'est ce qu'on attend de vous
concrètement si vous étiez dans une
série de fiction les on voudrait faire
quoi pour résoudre ce n'est pas ma tête
le meurtre ou suicide de monsieur
poutine dont on parle de l'usc web n
était pas forcément ce qui nous vient en
tête quand on pense au fbi aux enquêtes
criminelles mais l' expertise
particulière pour laquelle j'ai été
invité à faire partie du groupe de
travail du fbi ainsi au niveau des
analyses statistiques
donc j'ai pas sûr que c'est que ça passe
très bien la télévision mais si on fait
pour cette raison là parce que quand on
obtient des correspondances par exemple
entre le profil génétique qui a été
obtenu sur une scène de crime et l'adn
d'un suspect mais on se demande toujours
c'est quoi la force de cette
correspondance là c'est quoi la valeur
statistique qu'on peut attribuer à cette
preuve adn donc c'est là que les
statistiques deviennent importantes
parce que j'avais du champ pour ça
suffit non exactement donc on va
toujours avec des probabilités
même si les chiffres sont énormes et
qu'on est dans les centaines de
milliards c'est pas du 100 %
en même temps je pense que la complexité
c'est aussi la conjugaison de plusieurs
adn
présent sur le présent sur une scène de
crime
oui exactement dont canadienne a
commencé quelques années les méthodes
étaient beaucoup moins sensible on avait
besoin d'une grande quantité adn pas
être capable d'avoir un résultat
maintenant la technologie s'est raffinée
et on est capable de détecter de
beaucoup plus faible quantité d'adr
ce qui fait qu'on analyse qu'on appelle
des objets manipulés par exemple si je
faisais un prélèvement sur votre volant
de voiture probablement que je
retrouverai votre adn
ce qui fait que lorsqu'un objet est
manipulé par plusieurs personnes par
exemple un marteau qui peut avoir servi
à commettre un crime
si on fait un prélèvement sur le manche
du marteau ont pu retrouver l'adn de
trois quatre cinq personnes et c'est là
que les nouvelles méthodes statistiques
qui ont été développées deviennent
intéressantes et permettent d'analyser
ces résultats complexe qu'on ne pouvait
pas analysé précédemment avant
l'avènement ce qu'on peut le faire
maintenant qu'est-ce que permis de le
faire mais en fait c'est des modèles
mathématiques très complexe qui ont été
intégrés dans des logiciels qui sont
maintenant disponibles
ça veut dire que votre travail de
biologistes qui consiste à examiner
peut-être des cellules des molécules je
ne sais trop le sait vous le
scientifique
vous aviez vous passez maintenant dans
un mode presque de hautes technologies
et modèles format tic c'est ça oui enfin
il ya toujours eu des calculs
statistiques associés aux résultats
l'adn la ses calculs statistiques là
sont un petit peu plus complexe c'est à
dire qu'il ya plusieurs ya plusieurs
équations qui rentrent en ligne de
compte
donc c'est ça se complexifie
effectivement mais ça nous permet
d'aller plus loin dans notre analyse à
une sélection ce qui vous vient à
l'esprit d un exemple de résolution d'un
crime grâce à ces nouvelles techniques
mais en fait eu plusieurs résultats pour
lesquels et pouvait y avoir des
résultats
complexe comme je vous parlais tout à
l'heure avec l'adn de 4 ou 5 personnes
dont on était capable de voir que dans
ce prélèvement le sur la scène de crime
on avait la dn 2 3 4 5 personnes mais on
n'était pas capable de de faire de
correspondance avec un super donc
maintenant ces résultats vont pouvoir
être cultivée
on va souhaiter bonne chance dans ce
débat aussi beaucoup de plaisir
merci beaucoup madame noël et au plaisir
de voir parler merci merci